♪♪
-Hey, guys.
I'm so excited about this.
-Look at this outfit.
-Oh, my goodness.
It's the real me.
I'm so excited.
We are riding "The Beast."
[ Growl ]
Actually, I heard
it could get a little wet.
-Oh.
-You guys ready
to ride "The Beast"?
-Yeah!
-Why does it have to
row like this?
-Because we're in water.
-Oh.
-Look at New York.
Oh, my God, look.
Isn't that pretty?
♪ -Come sail away, come sail
away, come sail away with me ♪
-Bum-bum, bum-bum!
♪ -Come sail away, come sail
away, come sail away with me ♪
♪ -Don't throw up on me ♪
♪ Don't throw up on me,
don't throw up on me ♪
-Hi, New York.
-Working girl. Working girl.
[ Boat horn blows ]
-Yay!
-Oh!
-Jesus!
-This might be a bad time,
but is the ascot too much?
-No. Give it to me
so I can wrap my head.
-Thank you.
-Karamo, how you doing?
-Oh, no.
-Oh, Jesus Christ!
-Alright.
-Oh [bleep]
-Okay, we get it.
-Oh, my.
[ Laughter ]
-Aim that way.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Oh!
-No!
Oh, oh, ew!
-It's so hard to make it sexy.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoo!
-Oh, oh!
-Puking.
-Is he barfing?
-Ooh!
[ Screaming ]
[ Laughter ]
-Karamo, are you okay?
-Aah! Jesus Christ!
♪ -Some people wait a lifetime ♪
♪ For a moment like this ♪
[ Indistinct singing ]
♪ I can't believe
it's happening to me ♪
♪ Some people wait a lifetime
for a moment like this ♪
[ Laughter ]
-I'm the king of the Hudson!
[ Cheering ]
-That was so good.
Like, Karamo --
-That was the worst thing ever.
Worst thing ever.
-I actually didn't think
it was that bad.
I didn't even get that wet.
-I know. It was so shocking.
You look pretty good.
-Just, like, a little drop of --
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
♪ -Come sail away, come sail
away, come sail away with me ♪
-I want to just go back
a little bit
and just see if there's any hair
or fashion or style choice
that you've made mistakes
in the past.
I have some photos I want
to show you, just so...
-Oh, yes.
-Oh, please be Bieber.
Please be the Bieber look.
Oh, no.
-Tan. You had a haircut
that you tried out.
-I did. I will --
-This works for you.
-Thank you. And so I wasn't
always known for my hair.
-I think you were, though.
-Leave me alone.
That is so mean.
You are so vile.
So vile.
Here's the thing. Like, I --
I like to believe that
I started a certain trend
and then this megastar
decided to copy me.
-You're telling me --
-You'll see what I mean.
-You're telling me that you had
a Bieber cut before Bieber?
-He didn't realize it was me
who inspired him.
-Early Bieber.
-Yeah.
-He was giving that --
-Oh, yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
-Tan, that is
the worst thing ever!
-What you don't see
is the white leather belt
that he was wearing
with that look.
-Oh, really?
-And the fist pump.
And the fist pump.
-Wait. No. Wait, wait, wait.
-I like the fist pump.
-Look how pretty I look!
-Oh, my God.
-Beautiful.
-Bobby --
-Adorable. You are adorable.
-Bobby, your regrettable...
[ Laughter ]
...fashion faux pas
was from actually --.
-Yeah, it was just like
a year ago, I think.
-Walk me through it.
-Um, well --
-That was before
I got to your color.
That was before
-You know, there was
a very specific look, I think,
that producers in the beginning
had in mind for me.
I think -- They're like --
Lies!
-..."He's the blonde one.
He should dress like Carson
dressed in the original."
It worked for Carson.
-You liked --
You liked wearing clothes
that were the same color
as your skin.
It was lovely.
-You know, and in my defense,
it was also like 108 in the
summer in Georgia on that day.
-I don't think it's --
-Can I just say? Can I just say?
-Yes.
-Like, Bobby, our journey
together and hair color
has been amazing, I feel.
Because wow. The most improved.
-This is natural.
-I know. Most improved look.
So beautiful.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Our journey together."
Karamo.
-Yeah?
-You think you're --
You had a -- You wore --
-Yeah.
-Oversized clothes?
-Oversized clothes.
I mean, anybody who's a product
of the early 2000s,
listened to hip-hop,
your clothes were like
three times oversized.
And so --
-Let me see.
-Yes!
-It's not bad.
-It's back in style.
-I want that, honey.
-I don't mind it.
-I'm into it.
-That's a good photo.
That's, like, legit,
a good photo.
That's, like,
a really bad humble brag.
-Shiver my timbers. Gorgeous.
-"Shiver my timbers."
Oh, my God.
Antoni, you had -- you had
an interesting hairstyle.
I had a lot of hair.
[ Laughter ]
I'm growing it out now again,
but it was -- anyway, yeah.
-No, it looks great.
But here's -- here's an old --
a nice photo of you.
-Aww!
-Wow.
-Oh, no!
-My face was a circle.
[ Laughter ]
-You couldn't even see anything.
-Yeah, I was very round.
I partied a lot in my early 20s.
-Oh, you look good.
-Yeah.
-Who's that girl?
-It starts with the floppy hair.
It was really cute.
-It's really
Ashton Kutcher-esque.
-Yeah. Definitely.
-There you go.
-Yeah.
-Jonathan.
Any -- Any mistakes?
-I -- You know, I just --
I've literally just been this,
like, beacon of personal style
and good decisions
my whole life.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
So I don't have any --
I don't, I don't, I don't.
I wanted to participate,
but I didn't have -- I just --
You know,
there's no bad pictures.
-This must have been
so uncomfortable for you.
-It was.
I was like, "Uh..."
-You're just so perfect.
Yeah.
I want to talk about this,
'cause I was actually
gonna suggest to you guys, like,
you should go to Europe
or do something, you know,
to do --
-We love Europe.
-Yeah.
-You do?
I mean, but then I found out
you filmed the show in Japan.
-Yeah.
-Yes.
-It's so magical.
In my opinion, they're some of
the most incredible episodes
we've ever done.
-Really?
-It's because
our cultures are so different.
And they're just the most
beautifully kind
and sweet and civil people.
-And organized!
And on time.
And --
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It made my heart sing!
-Yeah, it is true.
Bobby, you were in your element.
-Are you a big deal in Japan?
-No, nobody knew who we were,
which was kind of nice,
because with the show, now
people kind of know who we are,
so when we walk in,
they're like,
"Oh, Tan, dress me, and, Karamo,
don't make me cry!"
And so things like that,
and so --
-"Don't make me cry"?
-That's usually what I get.
-Yeah.
-"Please don't make me cry."
-Dude, do people cry
when they run into you?
-Oh, my gosh.
Literally, people come up to me
on the street and immediately
they'll start crying.
And I'm like,
"Nice to meet you, too."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-It's really sweet.
But I like it.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, why not?
-Why not?
-I love every segment
of the show.
Each one of you do a great job,
but, Karamo,
while we're talking to you...
-Yeah?
-...is there anything
you can tell our audience
and like...?
'Cause you're, like --
You get in --
You're like therapy for --
-Yes.
-And could you give us something
that we can go out on?
-Yes. Everyone, turn to your
neighbor and say, "Neighbor."
-Oh, he's doing it.
-Neighbor.
-"I am loved."
-I am loved.
-"I am beauty."
-I am beauty.
-"And I am worthy."
-And I am worthy.
-You guys have gotten
pretty close.
But I just want to see
how close you are
in a game we call
"Know Your Fab Five."
Now, here's how the game works.
One of you will be wearing these
noise-canceling headphones
while the other four answer
a question about you.
Then you take the headphones off
and we'll see
if your answer matches.
Makes sense?
-Okay.
-Alright, here we go.
Antoni, you put on
the headphones first.
-We'll pass it down.
-Yeah, thank you.
-Oh, yeah.
-God, it's like "Miss Universe."
It's like "Miss Universe."
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, ready? Alright.
So, Antoni -- Antoni can't hear.
-Can you hear? Can you hear?
We love you.
-Oh, good. He can't hear.
I love it. Alright.
Alright, when is the hardest
that Antoni laughed
while filming
and what is the story behind it?
-Ooh.
-He laughed pretty hard when
Jonathan snotted himself
when we're -- when we were doing
that -- the cheerleading thing.
-Oh, yeah. Yeah.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Tell me about it.
-You were sitting there in
your little cheerleading outfit
and you laughed and you snotted.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It has to be one of the scenes
where he's eating something --
-No, no, no, no.
The scene where Shannon --
he gave away Shannon.
-Oh, yes!
-The engagement.
The engagement.
-We had an engagement episode.
-He didn't laugh.
He didn't laugh.
-He was embarrassed.
-He was mortified.
-Yeah, I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-Not when did he cry.
So, laugh -- you think when
Jonathan snotted at himself.
-Yeah, Jonathan snotted himself.
-Yeah, yeah,
that was a pretty --
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, alright.
Okay, take it. Alright.
-This is the weirdest song
ever played on that.
[ Laughter ]
-I know. it's perfect.
I know. it's so good.
The question was when is
the hardest that you laughed
while filming and what is
the story behind it.
-The hardest that I've laughed.
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
Oh! Oh! Okay.
Okay, so, it was actually
when -- it was --
[ Laughter ]
It was during our press shoot
for season --
-Yes!
-Wait, it was during our
press shoot for season four.
And we were dressed
as cheerleaders.
-Yep.
[ Laughter ]
And Jonathan tried to do
a really sexy pose.
And he sneezed.
And he got, like, a cup of
boogers in his beard.
[ Laughter ]
They went everywhere.
I actually peed myself.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You got it.
-Of course you got it.
-This is for Tan.
-Tan?
-Yeah.
-Oh, I'm sorry, Tan.
[ Laughter ]
-It'll be fine.
-By the way,
I think Bobby's probably
gonna get all these answers.
-I'm shocked we got him to put
those on over his hair.
-I know.
[ Laughter ]
-Can you hear?
You can't hear, okay.
Perfect.
-Can you hear?
[ Laughter ]
-Jonathan has described Tan
as the smartest of the five.
What is the dumbest thing --
[ Laughter ]
What is the dumbest thing
you've seen Tan do?
-Oh, my gosh.
He put on that camo halter top.
-No, that was one of the most
beautiful things he's ever done.
-I know what it was. This is
gonna be really embarrassing.
He's gonna hate me for it.
When we were in Japan,
he pretended
that he had food poisoning
because Tan loves a pastry
and Tokyo has the best pastries.
And he tried to tell us
that it was food poisoning
from eating
too much mini pastries.
-He wasn't sick?
-He had the stomach flu,
and he was like,
"Oh, it's from pastries."
And we were like,
"No, you don't get the flu
from eating baked goods."
[ Laughter ]
And it was the dumbest
'cause he thought
we were dumb enough
to believe him.
-Wow!
So, alright, alright.
-He was violently ill.
-He had a halter top on
in season three.
Like, it was a camo halter top.
And I think that was the dumbest
thing he ever did.
-Or the blue mohawk.
-I think the answer is Tan has
never done anything stupid.
-No, it's the blue mohawk.
I'm gonna say --
he's gonna say --
He's gonna say the blue mohawk.
-Okay.
-He will?
-From season one.
That's what I think.
-Okay.
-That's really the worst.
-Thank you very much.
By the way, that is my album.
[ Laughter ]
Be careful, yeah.
The question was
Jonathan has described you
as the smartest of the five.
That's really nice.
But what is the dumbest thing
that they've ever seen you do?
What was the dumbest thing
you've ever done?
-Ooh.
Gosh, I do a lot of --
Don't hate on me.
I don't do much stupid stuff.
-Right?
-Oh, my God.
-However, there is one.
It wasn't what I did on set,
but I think I told you all
I met -- I met Viggo -- I met
Nikolaj from "Game of Thrones."
-Yes.
-Beautiful, beautiful man.
-Jaime.
-Yeah.
-Oh.
-Nikolaj Coster-Waldau.
-Yes, yes, yes.
Okay, so, I met him.
He asked for a picture,
wonderful.
I said, "Oh, I'll do
a video for your daughter."
Because his daughter
is a big fan of "Queer Eye."
And I kept calling him
Viggo Mortensen. Viggo.
"Yeah, sure, Viggo." So I did
the video of him, saying,
"Your dad, Viggo, is, like,
the best dad on the planet."
And then I walked off,
left him with the --
I went back and sat in the car
with my publicist.
And they're like,
"That's not Viggo Mortensen."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
[ Sad trombone plays ]
Wow! That is a bummer.
-So sad.
-We said it was
when you put the --
I said it was when you put
the blue mohawk on.
-I said, "Tan has never done
anything stupid."
-I don't do stupid things.
-I said remember when you
wore the camo for the --
-That wasn't stupid.
That was adorable.
-That was so cute.
-Tan, when you ate --
[ Laughter ]
When you ate all the pastries
and you told us you had the flu.
-That was bad, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But what I will say about
that camo is my titties --
my titties
have never looked better.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This last one is for Jonathan.
-Okay.
-Alright.
-I'm so excited. This is going
really well for me.
-You're gonna love this song.
This song is so good.
-I just need to say something
really quick.
Bobby, you need to be on your
best behavior for this question.
You're on national television.
-Oh, my goodness.
Jonathan, don't warn us.
-We don't threaten.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Jonathan brings positive energy
everywhere he goes.
What is his most obvious tell
when he's starting
to feel cranky?
-Ah.
-Oh.
-"I hungry."
-No.
-"I hungy."
[ Laughter ]
-"I hungy?"
-When he yells --
when he yells, "Julie!"
-That's his assistant.
-When he says "Julie" --
-"Julie!"
-"Julie," we knew it.
-Like that.
-We know to tell Julie to run.
-I want to hear "I hungy."
What is that?
-"I hungy."
-She gets hungry.
-Yeah.
-"I hungy. I need a snack!"
-"I'm a hungy baby."
-We have two things. "Julie!"
Or "I'm hungy."
-"I'm a hungy baby."
-The best one, "Where is she?
Where is she?"
-Oh, yeah, it's "Where is she?"
-He's referring to his coffee.
"Where is she?"
-"She's cold. Why is she cold?"
-"Where is she?"
-Okay, yeah, it's any of those.
-Alright, alright, alright.
Jonathan, Jonathan, here you go.
-I already know
I hate you so much.
-Alright, Jonathan, it's very --
it's actually -- the answers --
there's three really good
answers. But anyways --
-Don't let us down, Jonny.
-You bring positive energy
everywhere you go.
What is your most obvious tell
when you're starting to feel
a little cranky?
-Well, you know, anytime I've
been around these four too much,
it's --
[ Laughter ]
It's something that -- I'm just
kidding. I love them so much.
I usually --
well, what I said before,
when I saw your guys' hands
going like this,
that makes me feel like I must
do this with my hands.
-You are so uncomfortable
right now.
-No, I -- what I -- I feel like
what I do is, like,
I feel, like,
there's a lot of toe tapping.
I also will do, like,
a very clenched -- like --
-Oh, yes, you do.
-You love a clenched --
-Oh, yeah. You do do that.
[ Laughter ]
-And his temple twitches.
-His temple twitches, yeah.
-How long does it take
to run that errand?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
-You know?
I'm a fan of punctuality.
Okay, like, God?
Like, from other people.
-How about do you recall saying,
"I hungy?"
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
I'm normally in a good mood
when I say that.
-Or "Where is she?"
-When you said --
Either "Where is she?"
or "Julie!"
-"Julie!"
-Oh, yeah, that is -- yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That is it.
-That's it.
-That's the take right there.
-It's so great to see you.
Thank you for coming back.
-Thanks for allowing us back.
-The last time we were
all together was, like,
summer of 2020, I want to say.
-Remember summer of 2020?
-♪ It was the summer of ♪
-2019.
-2019. It was 2019.
-In person. In person.
-Because we went on a boat,
like, in 2020.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Remember? Karamo threw up?
It was a whole thing.
-That's right. Karamo.
Yeah, by the way,
he's not here tonight.
We will say --
-Because he's throwing up again.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-He's feeling a little --
He's not gonna risk it.
-[ Overlapping dialogue ]
-We love you. We love him.
-Let's go through all of you,
because we had --
A lot of things have
happened since you've
all been here together.
Tan, you've become a father.
-Yeah!
-Little bitty baby.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-My little baby Ismael.
I was shocked that --
Well, we got so close that --
Jonathan carried my child
for me, which was really sweet.
[ Talking over each other ]
-The bounce-back was real,
honey.
-You did such a good job
with the labor.
Thank you so much.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Ismael.
And he is 6 months old,
and he is just --
I love him so much.
-Jonathan, you announced
that you're married.
-What?
-Yeah!
-Congratulations!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Jonathan!
-I did it. I did it, I did it.
-Wait, wait. What -- How --
Are you loving married life?
-It is really so much fun.
He's, obviously, stunning.
And, yeah, I'm, like, married
and it's, like, really fun.
And who knew?
-I knew.
-Wait. Well, you knew.
-You knew. You knew.
-Well, who knew?
I grew up in a time when, like,
marriage equality
wasn't a thing.
And so I'm so happy that
I get to be on this journey
and get to share my life
with someone who is so hot.
And it's just so much fun.
-Bobby, you did something
that not many people can say.
You were on "The Masked Singer."
-I was a pig --
-A caterpillar
on "The Masked Singer."
-He was so good.
-It was great.
-Thank you, thank you!
And the largest costume
in "Masked Singer" history
and the heaviest
and also the hottest.
I think it was about
120 degrees in there.
The first performance,
I about passed out.
The second performance,
I learned to have them
put me in an ice vest,
and it was completely
packed with ice.
It was the best.
I'm going to wear them now
when we film in the hottest
states in America next season.
-Antoni, it's always good
to see you.
Everyone on the Internet
is talking about this.
On the show, out of nowhere,
let's just say,
there's little bumpers, there's
things, there's action shots.
You rescued a dog.
-I did.
-Congratulations.
-Thank you so much.
-Neon.
-Neon the Mutt,
if you want to follow her
on socials.
-Yeah. Okay. Good.
-She's a lovely,
lovely Pit rescue
from a really great organization
in Austin
called Austin Pets Alive!
where you also adopted.
They really do God's work.
-There was something
that we saw on the show
that everyone was,
like, talking about
probably because of the dog,
I'm assuming.
-Absolutely.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, here's a photo
of you washing the dog.
Yeah, so, clearly --
-I like how she's staring
right at his belly button.
[ Applause ]
-It was a very hot day!
-Oh, really?
He was a masked caterpillar!
Okay?
[ Laughter ]
We need to talk "Queer Eye"
because, man, oh, man.
Always --
You know I love the show.
And I'm not just saying that.
And the first episode
always gets me.
And I go, "Oh, yeah."
But this one
really, really got me
because when
you started filming,
it was right before
the pandemic.
-Yeah.
-So you were in Austin, Texas.
You're filming.
It's an amazing story.
Moving.
And then there's no end.
Like, Tan, what was going down?
-You know, we went into this
thinking, "Yeah, maybe
the pandemic isn't gonna
really take off in the U.S.
and we'll just go
shoot the show."
And then, literally, a few days
later, we had just finished --
You know when we do the reveal
where we show them the home,
we put them in the new outfit?
We had done that.
And then we left
for the weekend
and we just didn't come back
for over a year.
And so this was the first time
ever on "Queer Eye"
where we got to see
how our lessons
were taken on by our hero.
And so a year later,
we got to revisit
and how life changed so much.
She'd been through so much.
-I was like -- 'Cause you go --
Sometimes you see these shows
and you go like,
"Oh, yeah, they changed
their life
or they changed their hair."
And then a year later,
they're back to normal.
Her life actually changed,
and it was just so beautiful.
You guys are gonna freak out
if you haven't seen it already.
It's so cool.
And it is so good.
-You're making me teary-eyed.
-I love you.
-Well, because
it's bittersweet.
-It's just a beautiful thing,
and it's real.
And it's so awesome.
The whole season is awesome.
I just want to say
congrats, also.
This might be the awesomest.
You guys are officially Legos.
Did you know that?
-Isn't that wild?
-My childhood dream come true.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Officially.
-It's so wild!
-What does that feel like?
-It's pretty freaking cool.
It was my favorite toy
growing up. And -- Yeah.
-People are gonna step on you
guys and scream to the moon.
-I was hoping -- I was hoping --
I have this fantasy that, like,
Ted Cruz's or Mitch McConnell's,
like, nephew or niece
are, like, nibbling,
someone's going to sneak them
a "Queer Eye" Lego set.
And then it's going to, like,
fall off the table.
And, like, my Lego will be
underneath one of their feet
and they'll just be like, "Ow!"
-Playing tonight, we have
the cohosts of "Queer Eye" --
Jonathan Van Ness,
Antoni Porowski,
Tan France, and Bobby Berk!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yes!
-Thanks.
Thank you.
-Whoo!
-And their opponents...
-The winners.
-Jimmy Fallon, J.B. Smoove,
Questlove, and the James Poyser!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
[ Laughter ]
Okay! First up.
Oh, there you go.
Nice, nice, yeah,
little, yeah, nice shot.
-I'm so nervous.
-Okay, first up,
Jimmy and Jonathan.
Come on up.
-Oh, my God.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-OM.
-I'm so nervous.
-Oh, my God.
-Here's how the game works.
-Yeah.
-I will read you the start
of an Internet search question
and you will fill in the blank.
-OK.
-You'll both type in
your answers as fast as you can
-Oh, my God.
-and then, we'll match them,
to see if any of them go
with the top 3, okay?
Okay, here's the first search.
♪♪
-Keep it clean.
-Ready, type in the answers.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughing ] No, Jonny!
-Aw, Jonny.
-Okay, Jimmy,
what did you write?
[ Laughter ]
-I wrote...
-Kiss.
-Jonathan, what did you write?
Have sex.
-Do we have any matches?
[ Cheering and applause ]
-There you go.
-Kiss!
-Oh, no!
-Come on, let's go, okay!
-Nice.
-[ Laughs ]
-It's okay.
[ Voices overlapping ]
It's okay.
-Okay, J.B.
-Yes.
-On a first date,
should you blank?
-Mm!
-What's your answer?
-Two more.
-Two more spots.
-I know what it is.
-Go Dutch.
-Go Dutch! Let's see go Dutch!
-Whoo!
-That's what I would pick.
-Go Dutch?
-That's a good one.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah!
[ Voices overlapping ]
-Oh, no!
-I was shocked!
-That was good.
-You know how many dates
I went on?
You know how many dates I've
been on before I got married?
Come on, man!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no!
-Okay, Quest.
-Go to dinner?
-Yeah.
-Go to dinner.
Let's say go to dinner.
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh!
[ Audience ohs ]
-No results.
-You guys can steal.
What do you say?
-Aah!
-Get together.
Think of an answer.
-Pressure.
-Get together, everyone.
-Pressure's on.
-Come on, come on, come on.
-What is it?
-Between kiss and pay...
-Be hot.
-No, no, no.
-What is it? What is it?
What is it? Come on, come on.
-What do you think?
What do you think?
-Hard kiss.
-Handy!
Like handsy -- handies.
-A handy.
-Handy.
-Not a handy.
[ Laughter ]
-It's not a handy!
It's not that!
-It's a family show.
-You can't say that.
-Can't say that.
-It's not that.
-You can't say any
of those words.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You guys have an answer?
-Talk about their exes.
-Let's see talk about your exes.
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh!
-You win.
-We win! We win! We won.
We won, baby.
We win! We win!
-What was it?
-Let's see
what the last answer was.
♪♪
[ All ohing ]
-Awful.
Awful people.
Okay, time for Round 2.
J.B. and Antoni, you're up.
Let's go.
♪♪
-Antoni, come up here.
Get ready to type in.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Get ready to type in
your answers.
-I got this. I got this.
I'm feeling good.
-Alright.
-You feel good?
-I feel good.
-Complete this search question.
♪♪
-Yeah.
-Type it in as fast as you can.
-Tan, don't say anything.
-Lock it.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Lock it in.
-That's a good guess.
-Oh, yeah.
-Okay.
-Antoni, what did you write?
-What's wrong with my child?
[ Laughter ]
-Child?
[ Applause ]
[ Voices overlapping ]
-I literally Googled that
last week.
-J.B., what did you write?
-And I write,
"What's wrong with my mind?"
-Mind.
-People say that all the time.
"What am I doing?
What am I doing?
What's wrong with my mind?"
-[ Laughs ]
Let's see if that's right.
-Let's see.
-Let's see if there's a match.
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, no!
Okay, Antoni,
since you buzzed in first...
-Yep.
-...you get to guess again.
-Get to guess again.
-Can we help?
-Do I type it or do I say it?
-I think you just say it.
-I just say it.
-Can we help?
-Live it up.
-What's wrong with my car?!
-Yes.
-Let's see car!
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-Car!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Okay.
-Go back over there.
-Yes! Yes! Yes!
-Okay, Tan.
-Yeah.
-We needed that, America.
We needed that win!
-Yeah.
-What's wrong with my blank?
What's your answer?
-What's wrong with my skin?
-Skin.
-Good.
-Uh-oh.
-Good answer.
-Yeah!
-Let's see skin.
I bet that's up there.
[ Buzzer ]
-Come on!
-No, it's not.
-Good answer.
-I could've done that
-Bobby.
-sound effect for you.
-Health.
What's wrong with my health?
-Let's see health!
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh!
Chance to steal.
-Uh-oh.
-Guys got to huddle.
Chance to steal.
-I think it's phone.
-Phone?
Alright, Quest says phone.
James says wife.
-Oh!
-I say phone.
-Phone?
-Phone.
-Let's see phone!
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-No!
-There we go.
-We got the win.
We got the win on that one.
-Got the win on that one.
-Let's see what
that last answer was.
-Oh!
-Dog.
-I should've known!
-Oh, my God.
-You had it.
You had it.
And they did not listen.
Okay!
This is the final round.
-Oh, I'm nervous.
-The game -- Questlove, Tan,
you're up. Come on up.
-Let's do it.
-[ Chanting ] Tanny! Tanny!
-Let's go.
Tanny! Tanny!
-There we go.
-You'll win. You'll win.
-Thank you.
-Okay, ready?
-[Both] Yes.
-Okay, name a word
that completes
this Internet search.
-Okay.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-Mm!
-Oh, wait.
Let's say bippy.
-Hey, Tan, Tan.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Too specific!
-Yeah, I think that works.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Is everybody blocked in?
-Mm-hmm.
-Press Enter, the green button.
-Oh, you have to press --
Oh, there you go.
-Sorry.
-Okay.
Question, what did you write?
You buzzed in first.
-As a person with experience,
I would say the answer is hair.
-Hair!
Okay, Tan, what did you say?
-That felt too obvious for me,
so I thought ears.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Ears.
-I hate people touching my ears
and my neck, so, yeah.
-Really?
-Ears.
-Let's see ears and hair.
♪♪
-Yeah, Quest!
[ Cheering ]
-Okay, get back over there.
-We got this.
We got this.
-Okay, back to you, Jimmy.
Back to you.
Got one more strike.
-Hand?
No. Music?
Touch their...stuff?
Stuff.
-Stuff?
-Stuff.
-Let's see stuff!
-Oh, come on.
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, okay!
You guys get a chance to steal.
-Yes.
-The question is obviously
do you like their...
but we can't say it, okay?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-No, no, no, no.
-Like what's --
-Okay.
-It's "Do guys like it,"
not "Guys like it."
-What about butt?
That's what I said, butt.
-[ Chanting ] Butt, butt, butt,
butt, butt!
-I don't think that's allowed.
He said it's a TV --
-No.
Butt's fine.
-Because like Netflix,
we can say butt.
-We can say whatever.
[ Laughter ]
-Touch their...?
-Butt.
[ Voices overlapping ]
-Is butt your final answer?
-Yeah.
-Yeah!
-Let's see butt!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Buzzer ]
Oh!
Let's see what they were.
Let's see the answers.
-What are you Googling?!
♪♪
-Next one.
-Oh!
-I said face!
-We got the winners over here.
-I said face.
[ Applause ]
-You said ears.
-Judges, judges.
[ Voices overlapping ]
-Ear is a part of your face!
-Ears!
[ Buzzer ]
-It's right off of your face.
-I'll deal with you
after the show.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
My thanks -- We won!
-[ Cheering ]
[ Rimshot ]